this is the cost of political rivalry in
iraq dozens of people came to pay their
respects to the family of wasabrati
for nearly a decade the 38 year old had
been part of surai salaam the armed wing
of shiite politician mukhtar al-sadr's
movement
after suther announced yet again on
monday that he's retiring from politics
his forces fought with shiite rivals
supporting the iran-backed coordination
framework and iraqi security for hours
in the capital
wasam's eldest son ali is 15 years old
he is one of four and wassam's wife is
pregnant with their fifth child
wassam's brother at boss says his
brother was killed by a sniper who shot
him through an eye
we believe in the orders of muktara
al-sada to reform the state he's the
only man who can save the state but it's
a pity the coordination framework have
gone too far we offered them our 73
seats in parliament and told them to
form the government but they failed
many here say events of this past week
is a reminder of how much they need
souther to remain in politics
wissam was a member of saraya salaam the
armed wing of suther's movement his
older brother says his death only
reinforces their belief and dedication
to mukhtar al-sadr who they believe
isn't done with politics just yet
on the other side of town those from the
other side of this conflict laid their
victims to rest
those being carried here were members of
the popular mobilization forces
shiite armed groups that are now part of
the government's military
the prime minister addressed the nation
following the end of the violence on
tuesday evening with a warning
and i warn that if they want to continue
to create disputes and complications and
not to listen to the source of reason
then i will make a moral decision and
proceed to leave my post in accordance
to the iraqi constitution at an
appropriate time
this political upheaval is not new here
but scenes like this are in the heavily
fortified green zone area
and as quickly as they began they ended
when southern told his followers to stop
the bloodshed and leave
that highlights the immense power he
still has despite claims of retirement
and many are wondering how he will use
it next
door to jabari al jazeera baghdad